I mean this one killed me but it's it's
very popular online uh you brought your
phone and
um took a photo of Conan's thin lips and
tongue and turned it into your vagina
that's right it was that was so fun
because when when iPhones came out I
realized I could do that and then I and
then I remembered it when I was going on
so I was like oh this is perfect it's
perfect for uh and I was like and it's
like shows a vagina sound ostensibly
right
um but it's just Conan's mouth
you know that's it's not yeah but they
still they pick the latest they still
pixelated yeah so I took a picture of it
and then I turned it sideways and put it
in front of my crotch and it looked just
like a well not my vagina but a very
thin Irish vagina
oh you picked the right lips for them
and um yeah and but as soon as it went
between my legs it was pixelated I was
so mad but it still was funny obviously
okay I was in the studio and it was I
remember to this day it was oh it was
absolutely right visuals I it was
fantastic like turn to your head to the
side okay like this like this and then
just let your mouth I've been loose and
natural and maybe put but put your lips
together
and put your tongue out just a tiny bit
well a little more tongue
okay
hi
guys
now I really wish you still had the beer
and even with some pixelation they did a
good enough job pixelating it that you
can still see the sort of outline yeah
and you see it before it goes between my
legs like I think but I think I yelled
out the word vagina yeah because I'm
just like hey vagina I can't remember
what it is and then the next day he was
like watch the show tonight oh yeah and
there was a clip of a woman watching TV
watching it with her baby and I went
vagina and this tiny toddler just like
turns around and goes
I said wouldn't stop saying it I think
yeah oh it's great